ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนมีคะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีปี
ใหม่นะคะสวัสดี
ปีใหม่หาโอเควันนี้ครูฟ้ากับครูเอ๋ก็มา
เจอกันในบีกินเนอร์คลาสนะวันวันอะไรคะวัน
นี้วันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะวันนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีนะคะ
วันพระ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันนี้วันพฤหัสที่ 6 ค่ะ
ไปหัดที่ 6 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมกราคม
เดือนมกราคมแต่เดือนมกราคมโอเค
เปิ้มขอสอนก่อนคศเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ 2  022
ค่ะ
2022 นะครับ B ผชเท่าไหร่คะอีพศ.
ปีพต 2
565 นะคะวันนี้เราเจอกันวันพฤหัสตอนนี้
เวลาเท่าไหร่นะคะ
ตอนนี้เวลา
3:22 นาทีค่ะ 3 โมงนะคะ
22 นาทีครูฟ้ากับครูเอกก็จะพูดกันเสร็จ
ถึงกี่โมงคะ
15:50 น
15:50 นขอจริงๆเราพูดกันตอนตี 3:20 น
High  High ตอนเนี้ย
3:22 นนะคะก็ต้องพูดถึง
15:50 นทั้งหมด 30 นาทีนะคะ
30 นาที
กูเห็นลบได้
ได้ค่ะครูเอ๋ลบเลย
วันนี้นะคะวันนี้ครูเอ๋กับครูฟ้าก็จะมี
ของ
สิ่งของให้นักเรียนดูนะดูแล้วก็ฟังค่ะ
ดูกับฟังว่ามีอะไรบ้างนะคะก็ a  Stop
Sent  a นะคะ
มีคำถามด้วยเนาะอา
มีคำถามด้วยกับมีคำถามนะคะ
เดี๋ยวจะดูว่าครูฟ้ารู้แต่
ของที่ครูเอ๋มีไหมนะคะได้ค่ะคุณเอ๋
ชิ้นแรก
เห็นไหมเห็นไหม
ไม้บรรทัดไม้บรรทัดค่ะ
เก่งมากนะอ่าไม้บรรทัดนะคะครูฟ้าไม้
บรรทัดทำจากอะไรคะ
ไม้บรรทัดทำจากพลาสติกค่ะให้ค่ะไม้บรรทัด
ทำจากพลาสติกนะคะอ้า kuai มีไม้บรรทัด
แล้วนะคะนะต่อไปอ่ะอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะ
นี่เรียกว่า
มีดค่ะมีมีดนะคะมีดนะคะนี่ตรงนี้ตรงนี้
เป็นอะไรของนี่ค่ะ
ด้ามดำมีนะคะช่วงนี้เรียกว่าอะไรนะคะฝัน
สันมีดนะคะตรงนี้นะคะ
คมคมคงมีดนะคะอ่ะอ่ะมีบดำมีดทำจากอะไรคะ
ครูฟ้า
ด้ามมีดทำจากไม้ค่ะด้ามมีดทำจากไม้แล้ว
ตัวมีดทำจากอะไรคะตัวมีดทำจากเหล็กค่ะทำ
จากเหล็กนะคะอ้าเป็นเหล็กนะคะกูอีกวางนี่
ไปก่อนนะคะกลัวนเอาไปค่ะกูฟ้าอันนี้เรียก
ว่าอะไรคะอันนี้เรียกว่าดินสอค่ะเรียกว่า
ดินสอนะคะอ่ะหรอเนี่ย
ข้างนอกทำจากอะไรคะ
ข้างนอกทำจาก
กระดาษไหมไม้ My  Mind แต่พอไม้ไม้นะคะ
ส่วนข้างใน
ถ่านไม่ใน
ถ่าน
คาร์บอนถ่านอำเภอนาสีดำนะๆ
สีดำ
ช่องจากอะไรนะๆน่าจะเหมือนถ่านเนาะอ่ะ
เป็นไม้สีดำ
อ่านแล้วกูฟ้าอันนี้อะอะไรคะ
อันนี้ยางลบค่ะอย่างรอไปยางลบนะฮะยางลบ
ยางลบทำจากอะไรคะ
ยางลบทำจากยางยางจากทำจากยางราคาอ่ะและมี
อีกมีอะไรอีก
นิดเรียกว่าอะไรคะอันนี้เรียกว่าปากกาค่ะ
อ่านการ์กูฟ้าเห็นอันนี้ไหมเนี่ย
ป๋าเนาะปากกาตรงนี้ดำนะคะน้ำกับฝาปากกา
ภูฟ้ารู้ไหมทำจากอะไรคะ
ด้ามกับป๋าปากกาทำจากพลาสติกค่ะทำจาก
พลาสติกนะคะคลาสสิคนะฮะหาก่อน
เจอแล้ว
อันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะเรียกว่าซองห่าแต่
ว่าส้อมนะคะจะมีพิมมี
รูเห็นแล้ว
อันนี้นะคะเรียกว่าอะไรคะช้อน
องค์กร
ช้อนกับส้อมทำจากอะไรคะอันนี้ถอนกับส้มทำ
จากแตนเลทค่ะใช้ค่ะช้อนกับส้อมทำจาก
สแตนเลสนะคะอะกู xxx นะคะ
ได้ค่ะ
A มีอีกคู่ฟ้าอะไรคะคุณเอ๋
โอเคที่
กลมกลมๆนะรูดูตรงเนี้ยกรมกลมๆส่วนตรงนี้
เป็นตาข่ายอ่า
อันนี้เรียกว่าว่าอะไรคะครูฟ้า
กระ
แกงหรอ
กระชอน
กระชอนรัฐมอญหรอเอากระชอนอ้าวไว้กระชอน
ค่ะ
ทำจากอะไรเค้าเอกช็อตช็อตตัวนี้ตรงตรงนี้
นะคะทำจากสแตนเลสราคา
สแตนเลสอันนี้ก็จะเป็นเลท
สแตนเลสแล้วก็ด้ามด้ามกระชอนครูฟ้ารู้ไหม
ทำจากอะไร
ได้กระชอนทำจากพลาสติกค่ะดามกระชอนทำจาก
พลาสติกนะคะโอเคคู่ x เก็บนะคะเก็บที่พูด
พูดแล้วหวยเก็บ
โอเค
กลับไป
กูฟ้ารู้จักไหมอ่ะอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะ
อันนี้อ่ะแต่ว่าที่รองแก้วค่ะที่รองแก้ว
ที่เห็นรอแม่แก้วทำจากอะไรคะ
ที่รองแก้วทำจากไม้ค่ะที่รองแก้วทำจากไม้
นะคะทำจากแมงกลมเนาะกรม
j-pop มั๊ยค่ะครูป๋า
เป็น
เขียงเขียงเป็นอะไรคะเขียนเป็นรูปอะไรสี่
เหลี่ยมผืนผ้า
สี่เหลี่ยมนะคะสี่เหลี่ยมอากาศเรียกว่า
อะไรนะ
เขียงอ่ะเรียกว่าเขียงนะคะเขียนทำจากอะไร
คะภูฟ้าเขียงอันนี้ทำจากพลาสติกค่ะเขียน
ทำกราบพลาสติกนี้นะคะเก็บสีอะไรคะสีขาวสี
ขาวนะคะ
เก๋มีอะไรอีกคุยดูก่อน
กูเอมีอันนี้ค่ะครูฟ้า
ก็ฟ้าคะอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะอันนี้เรียก
ว่าอะไร
นะไม้ไม้พายหรอให้ไว้ภายหน้าคิดว่าไม้คาย
เตอะ
อะไรหรอไม่พายไว้ภายเรียกไว้ภายนะคะไม้
พายไม้พายอันนี้ทำจากอะไรคะ
ไม้พายนี้ทำจากไม้ค่ะไม้พายทำจากไม้นะคะ
เก็บค่ะเกรงเก็บนะคะ
ว่าไปค่ะครูฟ้าอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะอัน
นี้อ่ะแต่ว่าตะหลิวตะหลิวนะคะตะหลิวอ่ะ
ครูฟ้าตะหลิวเนี่ยโอ๋จะมีตรงนี้เป็นด้าม
จับนะคะอาจจะวิดามสำหรับจับนะก็ต้องนี้
เป็นด้ามเหมือนกันนะคะแล้วก็ตรงนี้ตรงที่
ตัดนะคะ
ตรงที่มือจับและหาด้ามจับเนี่ยทำหนักอะไร
คะอ่าตรงที่ที่ดาวจับมหาเสนทำจากพลาสติก
ค่ะทำจากพลาสติกนะคะแล้วด้ามตรงนี้นะคะทำ
จากอะไร
ตรงนี้ทำจากสแตนเลสไหมไอ้ห่า Time เหล็ก
สแตนเลสค่ะ
ตรงนี้นะคะทำจากอะไรคะ
ตรงนี้ทำจาก
เทปล่อนเหรอ
พลาสติกหรอเป็นคลาสสิคลง
ก็เป็น
โอเคอ่าตัวเองนะคะอาเห
มีอีก 1
อันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะครูฟ้า
อันนี้เรียกว่ากระทะค่ะเรียกว่า
อะไรนะกระทะกระทะนะคะกระทะอ่ะกระทะมีตัว
ตรงนี้นะคะเรียกมากตัวกระทะตรงนี้เรียก
ว่าอะไรนะคะด้ามจับน้ำจากนะคะโครงฟ้าดำ
จับทำจากอะไรน้ำจับทำจากพลาสติกค่ะอยาก
คลาสสิคนะคะกระทะทำจากอะไรคะกระทะทำจาก
เหล็กทำจากเหล็กนะคะ
มีอะไรอีกอ่ะ
ฮะ
โอเค
ไปวางก่อนนะคะกว่าอุ้ยขอโทษค่ะเสียงดัง
แฟนรู้จักไหม
เรียกว่าอะไรคะ
สายวัดสายวัดนะใส่วัดทำจากอะไรอ่ะ
พลาสติกค่ะหลายวัดทำจากพลาสติกนะคะ
หาก่อนนะคะหาหมอ
เก๋มีอันนี้ 5 กลุ่มป่า
แก้วแก้วนะคะเฮ็ดงานแล้ว
แก้วทำจากอะไรคะ
แก้วทำจากกระเบื้องกระเบื้องใช่ไหมคะตัว
นี้กระเบื้องวันนี้เรียกว่ากระเบื้องนะคะ
อ่ะถ้ากูเอาวาง
มีอะไรอีกตัวหาก่อนหากรู้ปัญหามีอะไรไหม
ฟ้ามีอันนี้ค่ะครูเอ๋
กูฟ้ามีอะไรคะอันนี้
ที่คั่นหนังสือ
หนังสือมีคั่นหนังสือนะคะหรือทำจากอะไรคะ
มีหนังสือด้วยนะคะอันนี้ที่คั่นหนังสือ
ที่คั่นหนังสือทำจากกระดาษค่ะทำจากกระดาษ
นะคะแล้ว
แล้วหนังสือนะคะครูฟ้าหนังสือครูฟ้าทำจาก
อะไรค่ะหนังสือครูฟ้านะคะก็ทำจากกระดาษทำ
จากกระดาษนะคะกระดาษนะคะเป็น
คู๋ฮะก่อนกูเอมีอะไรอีกหรอ
จะมีไหมนี่ๆๆ
นี่
โทรฟ้ารู้จักไหม
เรียกว่า
Bobo
นอนบินโบตอนนี้เป็นโบว์นะครับโบว์นะครับ
แต่ท่านดึงออกดึงนะคะดึงออกเราพูดว่า
ริบบิ้นนะฮะสิ้นหาขึ้น
ริบบิ้นทำตากอะไรเนี่ย
กระดาษไหมไม่ใช่กระดาษไหมฉีดได้กระดาษ
กระดาษ
ฉีกได้นะคะเรียนฉีกฉี่ฉีกได้อ้ะนั้นทำจาก
กระดาษนะคะอันนี้โบรู้จักกระดาษธรรมดานะ
คะอ่ะมีดีอะไรอีก
อันจะไร
กรรไกร
ทำจากอะไร
คะตัวกรรไกรตรงนี้ทำจากเหล็กค่ะเหล็ก
นะทีล่ะคะครูฟ้าเห็นไหมที่จะที่จับทำจาก
พลาสติกค่ะอ่าที่จะทำมาจากพลาสติกนะคะ
ตัวเอง
ชอบหาแว่นตาอุ้ยมองไม่เห็นแวะนา
ห้าสีฟ้าแว่นตาครูเอ๋นะคะอันนี้เรียกว่า
อะไรนะไม่ตาเนาะขั้นตาตรงนี้เรียกว่าอะไร
คะ
Password ขาแว่นตาแว่นตาราคาเนื้อหาแว่น
ตาหาอา
แว่นตะขาวแว่นตาเราก็ตรงนี้นะคะตรงนี้
เรียกว่าอะไรนะคะ
แว่นตาค่ะแว่นตานะคะครูฟ้าขาวแว่นตากับ
กรอบแว่นตาทำจากอะไรคะ
เหมือนๆกรรไกรเหมือนกันใกล้ฉัน
ขาแว่นตากับกรอบแว่นตาทำจากพลาสติกค่ะ
กรรไกรกรรไกรเหมือนกรรไกรอะนี่เหล็กหรอ
เหล็กค่ะ
ทำจากเหล็กค่ะอันนี้เป็นแว่นตาเหล็ก
เหล็กแข็งมากแข็ง
ๆแล้วก็
ตรงนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะ
เลนส์
เลนส์เลนส์แว่นตา
กูไปหารู้ไหมว่า
หลังจากทำไม๊
กระจกไหม
อันนี้ใช่กระจบจกอาเลนแวะตามีสองอย่าง
Classic
หรือหรือหรือกระจกนะคะหากเล่นตาครู
เอ๋เป็น
กระจกนะคะ
จบเลนส์แว่นตาครูฟ้าทำจากอะไรคะ
เลนส์แว่นตาครูฟ้าทำจาก
กระจกกระจกเหมือนกันกระจกนะคะมันจะหนักๆ
นะคะให้หนักค่ะเดี๋ยวเรามาทวนว่ามีอะไร
บ้างนะคะวันนี้ว่าได้เรียนรู้จักอ่ะเรียก
ว่าอะไรนะคะฟ้าแว่นตาแว่นตาแว่นตาก็จะมี
ขาแว่นตากรอบแว่นตาเลนส์แว่นตามีน้ำตา
Chloe อันนี้ทำจากเหล็กนะเล็กๆ
แวะนางปลูกฟ้าทำจากอะไรคะแว่นตาครูป๋าทำ
จากกระจกหน้าเลนส์แล้วก็ขาแว่นตาเป็น
พลาสติก
เบาๆใช่ไหมของกูเองไม่เป่าเจ็บ
ละก็นะคะก็จะมีมีดเนาะได้เรียนรู้จักมี
มีดทำจากเหล็กด้ามทำจากไม้นะคะ
แล้วก็อะไรนะคะครูฟ้ากรรไกรกรรไกรนะฮะ
กรรไกรทำจากเหล็กด้ามทำจากพลาสติกนะคะ
แล้วก็
อะไรนะคะกระทะค่ะราคากระทะทำจากเหล็กด้าม
ทำจากพลาสติกนะคะมีสิทธิ์รักอ้าอะไรนะคะ
เขียงค่ะเสียงนะคะเคียงเนี่ยอาจทำจากอะไร
ล่ะเขียงทำจากพลาสติกไหมใช่ค่ะทำจากรัฐสิ
นะคะ
อันนี้กระดาษนะคะ
แล้วก็ไม้ไม้พายนะคะไม้พายก็ทำจาก
หมายค่ะแบบทำจากไม้ราคา
ตะหลิวนะคะตะหลิวก็จะมีที่จะทำจากพลาสติก
ส่วนนี้เป็นอะสแตนเลสนะคะหลิบเราก็ตรงนี้
ก็เป็นคลาสสิคนะคะคือ
อะไรนะคะผู้บ้า
ถอน
ส้อมส้อมกับช้อน
โอเลย์ช้อนกับส้อมนะคะช้อนกับส้อมก็ทำจาก
อะไรน่ะทำจากอาจเสลดทำจากสแตนเลสนะคะทำ
เสร็จทั้งหมดชั้นที่จับนะคะก็เป็นสแตนเลส
ทั้งหมดนะคะ
แล้วแต่ปากการาคาด้ามปากกากับฝาอ่าฝาปิด
ทำจากอะไรนะคะทำจากพลาสติกค่ะเนื่องจาก
พลาสติกนะคะ
อะไรนะจำได้วางลบยางลบยางลบทำจังอะไรนะ
ยางลบทำจากยางค่ะจากยางเอาไว้ลบลบ
นก
นัดต่อไปนะคะอะไรนะ
กระชอนหน้ากระซ้อนนะคะเอากระชอนทำจากอะไร
นะคะตรง
กระชอนทำจากเสลดหรือว่าเหล็กกันแหละ
บางอันก็จะอลูมิเนียมแต่อันนี้สำคัญเลทนะ
คะเขาก็ด้ามจับนะคะดำจับทำจากอะไรนะ
พลาสติกค่ะทำจากพลาสติกตรงนี้เป็นรูเอา
ไว้แขวนนะคะเอาไว้แขวน
มีมี
ที่แขวนแล้วก็แขวนนะคะ
[เพลง]
มีที่รองแก้วนะคะที่รองแก้วจำได้ไหมทำจาก
อะไร
ที่รองแก้วก็ทำจากไม้ค่ะทำจากไม้
แล้ว
มีอะไรอีกนะเมื่อกี้นิเยอะเลยพี่
แก้วลืมมีแก้วแก้วก็ทำจาก
กระเบื้องนะคะหลังทำจากกระเบื้องนะคะ
แล้วก็มีหนังสือก็
ลืมลืมสายวัดนะคะ
นายวัดคะทรายนะทำจ้าจากคำจะพลาสติกค่ะสาย
วัดทำจากพลาสติกคะ
พลาสติกนะ
มีอะไรนะคะมีที่คั่นหนังสือดีชั้นหนังสือ
หรือทำจากอะไรนะคะหรือที่คั่นหนังสือทำ
จากกระดาษค่ะทำจากกระดาษราคาแล้วก็กูคะก็
มีหนังสือหนังสือหนังสือหนักหนังสือก็ทำ
มาจากกระดาษค่ะมาทำมาจากกระดาษ 555 งั้น
เนี่ยวันนี้เรามีของทั้งหมดอีกอย่างนะกู
เห็นน้ำก่อนนะคะเรียงมีอะเคนะคะมีหนึ่ง
กรรไกรนะคะ
สองอะไรคะแก้วแก้ว 3
มีด 4
กระชอนประจอน 5 ที่รองแก้วโห้
ดินสอ
ยางลบ
8 ปากกา
9 ซ่อม 10
ช้อน
10  11
ไม้พายไม้คาย
ตะหลิวอะหลิว
เขียงเขียงอาการคะๆ
สิริ 4
กระทะกระทะหมดหรือยังยาย
เอ๋
มีดกรรไกรไปแล้วอันนี้พูดหรือยังพูดกัน
แล้วค่ะที่เราแก้วไปแล้วค่ะ
15 ไม้บรรทัด
ยางลบไม่ใช่ใส่วัดใส่วัดในวัดนะคะสายวัด
อย่างรถไปไหน
ยังรถไปแล้วนี่ไปแล้วยังลบไปแล้วเราก็ 17
ที่ครูฝา
pic สือค่าที่คั้นหนังสือ
หนังสือหนังสือหรือนะคะทั้งหมดวันพรุ่ง
นี้เป็นของใช้นะคะของใช้นะคะ
19 แว่นตาแว่นตาแว่นตาก็เป็นของใช้นะคะ
คือใช้ก็มีทำจากพลาสติก
อะไรนะคะ
เหล็กแล้วก็ทำจากอะไรนะคะไม้ไม้นะคะมีของ
ใช้นะคะทำจาก
พลาสติกทำจากเหล็กทำจากไม้
ทำจาก
สแตนเลสนะทั้งชะนีขายกาหรี่ดังจากเสลดนะ
คะก็ทำจากกระเบื้องทำจากกระเบื้องนิแก้ว
แก้วทำจากกระเบื้องแล้วก็ทำจากอะไรคะคุณ
ครูฝาอันนี้ก่อนอันนี้ทำจากกระจก
ทำจากกระจกนะคะจกนะคะแล้วก็กระดาษขนาดทำ
จากกระดาษนะคะ
แต่ว่ามันก็จะเป็นกระดาษไม่เหมือนกันเนาะ
กากนิกรกระดาษกระดาษกระดาษจะมีเกรดดีๆใช่
ไหมกระดาษว่ากระดาษบางๆนะคะกระดาษแข็งๆ
แข็งอันนี้ก็
บาง
คลาสสิคก็เหมือนกันใช่ไหมคะพลาสติกบางๆ
นัดสิ
ติดบางๆแล้วก็นิ่มๆอันนี้เป็นพลาสติก
แข็งแข็งแข็งแข็งใช่มั้ยรกิจค่ะเป็น
คลาสสิคเหมือนกับนะคะอากาศอีกนิดเป็นของ
ใช้ที่บ้านน้ำตาลดีของใช้นักเรียนมีของ
ใช้ทำจากอะไรจริง
ชอบของใช้จากไม้
ร้อนจากไม้เราก็ชอบจากกระเบื้อง
ก็ว่าถ้าของใช้ที่ทำจากไม้สวยค่ะสวยนะ
หน้าก็
หรือกระทะนะกระทะเนี่ยมีกระทะอลูมิเนียม
กระทะ
สแตนเลส
อันนี้ก็เป็นต้นเทปล่อนเทปล่อนจะอยู่ตรง
นี้แต่ตรงนี้จะเป็นเหล็กใช่มั้ยเหล็กเลย
นะคะมาก็นักเรียนอะไรเข้าเขวนักเรียนก็
รู้จักของใช้แล้วแปลเวลาทั้ง
หมดหรือยังหมดแล้วหมดแล้ว
หมดแล้วนะคะก็ถ้านักเรียนมีของใช้ของใช้
ที่ทำมาจากเหล็กเสลดอลูมิเนียมหรือของใช้
อื่นๆนักเรียนก็คอมเม้นท์บอกได้นะคะงาน
ใช่ประชาก็
หมดเวลาแล้ว
ติดอย่าลืมกดไลค์กดแชร์แล้วก็กด Subscribe
นะคะนักเรียนก็จะได้ดูคลิปวีดีโอเยอะๆเลย
ค่าวันนี้ครูบากับตัวเอกก็ต้องให้ก่อนนะ
คะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบาย